next speaker is hello everyone welcome
to my talk on learning the best
algorithm for max code clustering and
other partitioning problems this is
joint work with Nena Belkin Ellen
rhetoric and Colin white a lot of free
real-world applications you face np-hard
problems such as clustering or max cut
and naturally these algorithms these
problems have resulted in many different
parametric families of approximation
algorithms and heuristics and a natural
question you would ask here is which is
the best algorithm according to some
objective that I care about and
typically you would answer this in terms
of which algorithm has the best
performance on the worst case problem
instance alright which algorithm has the
best performance on average overall
problem instances but a more natural
question to ask here which even Russia
talked about in his previous talk is one
where you are where you take into
consideration the unknown distribution
over problem instances that is defined
by your application and you evaluate
your algorithms according to their
performance in expectation over this
distribution so in my in this talk we
will consider two widely used families
of algorithms and we will show how you
can learn the best algorithm from these
families so here's a quick example
clustering is something that we face in
many different domains and in one
particular domain the kind of problem
instances that you may face may involve
clustering webpages by topic
and in another domain you might want to
cluster images by subject so it is since
it's NP hard for most clustering
objectors you there are many
approximation or heuristics such as a
ghulam later techniques which we will
see in the stock and the question here
is which is the best for my application
the honor the other problem that we
focus on is integer quadratic
programming which is a pretty abstract
problem that applies in many different
scenarios that
max 2sat and correlation clustering and
we focus on max Kurt during this in this
talk but our resource apply to integer
quadratic programs in general so there
are many so typically you would relax
the integer quadratic program to a semi
definite program and there are many ways
you can round the solution output by the
semi definite program to an integer I
describe this later in detail but we we
show how you can learn the best way in
which you can round this or the semi
definite program solution back to
integers so application-specific
algorithm selection has been studied
empirically for the past few decades in
AI and only recently Gupta and rock
garden proposed a learning theoretical
for this problem and this is a very
general model and we work in this so
first I will describe the model quickly
and then I will describe our results so
as I said I have a family of algorithms
possibly infinitely many and I also have
a performance metric say a cost function
which takes us input an algorithm runs
it on a problem instance ie
and outputs a cost value besides these
two as I said there's this unknown
distribution over problem instances
which exists in nature it tells me which
sort of problems are more typical to my
application so the ideal goal here would
be to pick an algorithm from this family
which has the best performance and
expectation over this unknown
distribution but of course that's to
ideal and what you hope to do is you
pick you draw some problem instances
from this unknown distribution and you
evaluate each algorithm over these
samples and then you pick the
empirically based algorithm so this is
the protocol which Britta and that
brings us to two important questions
here the first question is how do we
ensure that this algorithm that I just
picked based on the samples is also
close to optimal over the whole
distribution as you if you think about
it this is closely tied to how many
problem instances that a just sampled if
I had sampled a lot of problem instances
then I have a better idea of what the
distribution looks like
and hence I will be
and hence hence the performance of the
algorithms on those samples will be
representative of the expected
performance so the quit this boils down
to a sample complexity question and the
other question here is given these
samples how do I find the ompletely best
algorithm over these samples efficiently
even if this algorithm class was
infinitely large so we will see how this
question the sample complexity question
is answered by learning theory in order
to do that let me define something
called as cost sub a which is basically
a bunch of different functions one
function for each algorithm in my class
so each function here map's the problem
instance pays to the cost of running
that algorithm on all the problems in
this all the problems in the problem
instance space and what learning theory
tells me is that the sample complexity
needed for this near optimality
guarantee is is proportional to how rich
costs of base or the intrinsic
complexity of cost away which is
formalized as the notion of pseudo
dimension which I've seen then which
we'll see in the next slide let me know
if you have any questions here so what
is the pseudo dimension of cost sub a
here's how I will develop into intuition
for this so I want to know how rich this
function class is so let me pick pick
two problem samples i1 and i2 and let me
pick a function from cost sub a this is
going to map the problem instances to
cost values now if I were to pick some
thresholds I will induce a labeling on
these problem samples so big depending
on whether the cost is less than or
greater than the threshold now if I were
to pick a few other functions from cost
sub a will I be able to induce every
possible labeling on these samples so
this is the basic intuition behind
pseudo dimension and more formally the
pseudo dimension of costs are based a
single number which is basically the
size of the largest set of problem
instance samples that can be labeled in
every possible way by 2 power or s
different algorithms in a the each
algorithm corresponds to a function
the we could think of using the fad
shattering dimension that's a good point
but yeah we have focus on pseudo
dimension here yeah so it's does anyone
have any questions here so this brings
me to the domain results on clustering
so as you may already know a clustering
problem instance consists of endpoints
and the pairwise distances between them
and you want to partition these points
into K sets in order to minimize the
cost such as K means of K medium but I
will consider only an arbitrary cost for
the stock because our results apply to
any any such objective okay I'm going to
describe a rich class of clustering
algorithms each algorithm in this class
consists of two steps the first step is
a merge step so I begin with all the
data points in my problem instance as
singleton clusters and I'm going to
iteratively merge them to build a
cluster tree so in each iteration I pick
the two closest clusters and define what
that close closeness means but I will
iteratively pick two closest clusters
and bring and build a cluster tree so
each node in this tree is a cluster and
then I'm going to use dynamic
programming to find the best pruning of
this tree and output AK a clustering I'm
not going to get into the details of
this step but let's focus on the first
step so there are many different ways in
which I can define the distance between
two cluster nodes for example one
popular way is single linkage where the
distance between two cluster nodes is
the closest pairwise distance or
complete linkage where it is the
farthest pairwise distance or more
generally I can imagine an interpolation
between these two which I will call as
alpha linkage which consists which
basically weights single linkage with
the value of alpha and completely in
case with the value of one minus alpha
so alpha here is a parameter which which
defines a different notion of distance
and for each alpha I effectively have a
different algorithm in my algorithm
class and which is the best my
question no boils down to which is the
best alpha in my algorithm class and
more precisely assuming I have picked
some clustering problem instances I want
to pick the empirically based alpha is
the algorithm place clear exactly so we
will we will get to a richer class of
functions later on but just for the sake
of the talk for simplicity I'm gonna
consider this so okay so this brings us
to a key challenge here let's say I have
a single problem instance and a very
alpha across Z alpha line even a small
variation in alpha could possibly result
in completely different cluster trees
this is because we call that in a merge
step what I indeed have is a sequence of
merges and even if one of those modules
is going to change there could be a
cascade of many changes which I cannot
really trigger like which I cannot track
but so why is this exactly challenging
let's just quickly contrast this with
other machine learning classes where you
have a parametric function class rather
than a parametrized algorithm class and
as you vary the parameter you expect a
natural and intuitive change in the way
the function is going to change so there
it's going to be easier but for us we
don't know how the algorithm is going to
run differently with changes in the
parameter but we show that we can indeed
overcome this and this is how we show so
given a set s of problem instances we
take the Alpha lying and we explicitly
break that into polynomially many
intervals and what is special about
these intervals is that within each
interval different values of alpha
result in the same set of cluster trees
on the samples so when I jump from one
half on one interval to another interval
as I said I have no clue how these
cluster trees are going to change but I
have I do have this guarantee that
within a particular interval they'll
give me the same set of cluster trees a
fixed set set of cluster trees and
here's the intuition behind why that is
true recall that in the merge step yes
no it depends on the inputs so given a
set of problem instances I can
explicitly break the interval the range
of values of alpha so this is not a
global you know global partition like
independent of the inputs okay so the
intuition behind this is as follows
recall the merge step where in every
iteration I effectively do something
like this I take a pair of cluster nodes
a and B and another pair of cluster
nodes P and Q I look at the distance
between a and B and the distance between
P and Q and I compare these distances
and depending on the outcome of this
comparison my merge step go I mean I
decide what to merge in my merge step
but then let's okay let's vary Alpha
along the f4 line we can in fact show
something interesting which is that
there is exactly one value of alpha at
which the outcome of this comparison
flips okay and what is more interesting
is that that particular value of alpha
is the solution to this equation which
is in fact defined purely by eight
points which are namely the closest and
the farthest points in a and B and P and
Q so now if I simply iterate over the
all sets of eight points in my cluster
instance I can pick I can mark such
alpha you know four values on the line
and thereby L partition the whole alpha
line into n / 8 different intervals and
what is special about these intervals
within each alpha interval I have a
fixed outcome for any potential
comparisons that I will make so the
moment I fix all of them
I'm also fixing the cluster tree that
will be output for any alpha in those
intervals is that doesn't make sense
okay so we can similarly extend this to
s different samples and say that there
are like so many intervals such that you
have a fixed set of trees which also
means I have a fixed set prune so excite
of blue prune solutions and a fixed set
of costs which brings us to our pseudo
dimension bounds there what we show is
that the pseudo dimension of cost sub a
is in fact theta of log n ok so the
upper bound follows from this
from this very nice property that we
just approved so recall that the pseudo
if I have as many samples as the pseudo
dimension of course sub a I should be
able to pick to power s different alpha
values each inducing a different
labeling on the samples but indeed I
have just shown that if even if how many
other alphas I pick these are the number
of behaviors that I can expect from
those alphas for a fixed set of or
problem instances s so that results in
this inequality which gives me an upper
bound on the pseudo dimension so as I
said that's an abstract cost it could be
k-means or kmeans of distance to ground
through a clustering okay so as far as
the lower bounds concern it's a very
intricate analysis where we carefully
construct log n different clustering
instances that can be labeled in every
possible way by different values of
alpha along the alpha line okay so now
to find the best alpha for a given set
of clustering instances we only need to
first of all draw log n different
clustering instances that follows from
the pseudo dimension bound and we show
how you can solve for these polynomially
many intervals for that set of problem
instances and then we only need to run
the algorithm for one alpha per interval
because all the alphas result in the
same expected same empirical average
cost on this on the set of problem
instances at your sample then you can
see the it's straightforward to find the
empirically best interval of Alfred okay
so this so we also yeah there might be
many in any of them are going to be
let's say that there are two they
include easily so in practice then what
do you
after we you learn this alpha it's not
the first one alpha value 10 and you
want to take the best of the 10 so is
your question that I could use different
alphas on different problem instances
okay at the end to say okay in fact the
best thing for me to do is to 1/1 with
alpha I could one thousand once with
alpha equals two thirds and take the
best of the two and that's much better
than any one of them alone yeah so here
we pick a single alpha and I can see
that it could be possible to do
something like this where I pick
multiple different alphas maybe
depending on what the problem instance
looks like and even Russia has some
resource where they actually find a
mapping from parts of the problem
instance base to alpha values and so I
guess that sort of answers your question
because you're you're trying to find one
one of the franchise basically algorithm
to commit to once and for all yeah
that's okay so yes so this is a
straightforward efficient
computationally efficient and sample
efficient algorithm selection method so
we have more general resource where we
also consider a non linear interpolation
between single complete and average
linkage earlier we only had a linear
interpolation between those two and we
proved so a pseudo dimension bound of
theta of n of course because this is a
more a richer class of algorithms so we
have another set of general results
which is motivated by the following fact
if my cost function was something that
k-means okay median I can as well use
that in my pruning step as my DP
objective but if it was something like
distance to the ground truth clustering
there
these the ground truth clusterings are
provided only for the training problem
instances and I cannot legally use them
in my algorithm itself I can I should
only use a proxy objective in my pruning
step so what we consider is a much
richer class of algorithms where I not
only parameterize the merge step with
many popular algorithms many popular
linkage procedures I also parameterize a
pruning step with many are widely used
kinds of TP objectives and we prove
pseudo dimension bounds for this yeah
okay so yeah so what I am doing here is
competing with what is the best in that
class and so even given the class how do
I know which is the best to use let's
say I'm limited by that first but yeah
if I can see that there are limitations
to the class that I've just chosen okay
so that brings us to the end to the to
my resource on max on clustering so
going to max cut so as you all know in
max Kurt you you are given a graph G of
n vertices and edge weights and your aim
is to partition the set of vertices into
two in other words you want to assign
minus 1 or plus 1 values to these
vertices and here you have a particular
quadratic objective so unlike in the
case of clustering where I assumed when
I consider an abstract or an arbitrary
cost here I have a particular quadratic
objective which is nothing but the total
edge weight connecting a partition that
you just created as shown in the figure
there ok so our results apply to integer
quadratic programs more general integer
quadratic programs but as I say
focus on maxcut in this talk so here's
how so how am i doing on time so here's
how I how people popularly solve these
problems you have this integer quadratic
program which is which is hard to solve
so they relax that into a semi definite
program so I'm not going to get into the
details of this STP but all that you
need to know is that I find vector
assignments for the vertices instead of
integer assignments which means I'm
going to embed these points on an
n-dimensional unit sphere where n is the
number of vertices in the graph and now
in order to bring that back to a graph
cut solution I need to round it and the
richness in this method comes from the
fact that I could potentially use
different round in different rounding
methods and there's no one rounding
method that is clearly going to be the
best for my application so which is the
best rounding method from my application
so we consider our family of STP
rounding techniques that will propose my
FICA and Lango so each rounding
technique and this I in this family is a
randomized rounding technique in fact
there are two steps and both of them are
randomized so you so as I said there is
this embedding of points that is that
you can arrive at by taking a problem
instance and applying the STP now you
all you do is you choose a random
hyperplane in this embedded space this
this n dimensional space so once you
pick the random hyperplane I you can
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
assign plus or minus 1 values to these
embedded vertices in a random fashion
but then that the probability with which
I assign them to plus 1 or minus 1 is
dictated by how far these vertices are
from the hyperplane so if a vertex is
very close to the hyperplane I'm not
really sure whether they belong to plus
1 or minus 1 so with roughly equal
probability as sine I sign them to one
of them so if they are very far away
from the hyperplane my probability is
going to be skewed to either plus 1 or
minus 1 so more formally in order to do
this
I need what is known as a rounding
function which maps distances from the
hyperplane to probability values so in
particular they represent this popular
class of rounding functions called the S
linear rounding functions which are so
these are a bunch of different rounding
functions and each function in this
class is a piecewise linear function
there are three pieces with the middle
piece being parameterize by the
parameter s as you can see over there
okay so does anyone have any questions
you okay cool so okay but here's here's
one thing that I have to talk about
which is that since this each algorithm
here is randomized how do I assign a
performance value for each algorithm in
this class so each so each I've got them
in fact produces it results in a
distribution over performance values
depending on your random hyperplane
cross and this random assignment that
you do over here so what you typically
do is you look at the expected objective
achieved by each algorithm so I want to
pick the S with the best with the best
expected objective so more formally
recall that I want to bound something
that looks like this odd sub a which is
in fact a bunch of different functions
one function for each I've got them in
my class and each other algorithm is
defined by a parameter s which is the
parameter of the rounding function so
each function here maps the problem
instance face on the x axis to expected
objective values achieved by that
particular value of s so let's look at
this more carefully your object the
expected objective achieved by a value
of s on a problem instance is in fact an
expectation over the random hyperplane
drawers which is the outer expectation
and inside you have another expectation
which is an expectation over the random
assignments that you do based on the
rounding function but fortunately that
has a closed form expression so given
the rounding function and given the
hyperplane which are inputs so you have
s and the hyperplane and ie the problem
in students I have a closed form
expression button but what I actually
care about
here is is the full term that is odd OSS
kamae which turns out to be difficult to
handle because there is an expectation
of a hyperplane in the n-dimensional
space so how do we work on this so let's
consider something similar to ours away
which is off star Survey so just like
observation have star functions in this
class so for each value of s I have a
knob star so each for the function here
map's the problem instance face and the
hyperplane space to an expected cost
value so for a fixed value of s it Maps
a problem instance and a hyperplane that
I've picked to an expert an expected
cost value it's still an expectation
because it's an expectation over the
random assignments that I do but the
good thing is that this has a closed
form expression okay so what we show is
that the pseudo dimension of odd sub a
which is what we actually care about
because it gives us the sample complex
the guarantee is in fact upper bounded
by the pseudo dimension of all star sub
a okay so why is that good for us
because we we know what op star looks
like in each of these and we can hope to
bound the pseudo dimension of this
latter quantity and we in fact show a
bound on that which directly implies an
upper bound on the sample complexity so
let's look at our bound which is the
following so therefore we show that for
this class of algorithms defined by the
S Leaney rounding functions the pseudo
dimension of odd start sub a is Theta of
login again we prove a tight bound C
upward bound follows from the following
fact as I said our star has a closed
form expression which in fact looks like
this here Phi s is the S linear rounding
function parameterized by the value s I
is the problem instance which defines
the XIV values which are the embedded
points in the n dimensional sphere and
Hetch is the hyperplane that i've just
picked after the random hyperplane
picking step okay so if you look at this
it turns out that it it is in fact
piecewise quadratic or linear function
in s
so I have this line of s values and I
say I can partition that line into
pieces into at most n plus 1 pieces
where n is the number of vertices in the
graph and each piece is a quadratic or a
linear piece okay why is that
interesting
recall that in order to talk about
pseudo dimension bounds I picked these
thresholds for each problem instance and
then I see how different values of s
induces induce different labelings on
the problem instance with respect to a
particular threshold in fact over here
if I were to pick a threshold like this
it's going to partition s into n many
intervals such that within each interval
the labeling for all the s values in
that interval is fixed as you can see
over here ok so again now there's a like
how I prove the zero dimension bound for
clustering I can do something similar if
s is the know if it's a if S which is
the if capital S which is the set of
samples is as large as a pseudo
dimension then I hope that if I pick to
power s I can pick to power or capital s
different values of the parameter s
which give me different labelings of the
sample set but at the same time now I
know that there is this there is only so
many different values of the parameter s
that induce different wavelengths so
using this inequality I get an upper
bound on the pseudo dimension similarly
like how we did for the case of
clustering we also have a lower bound on
the on the pseudo dimension for which we
have we have this careful construction
of log n different input instances but
now the input instance is not just a max
cut problem instance but it's also a
hyperplane it's a market problem and the
hyperplane and instance so does anyone
have any questions
so now that I've established that you
can be sample efficient all I need to do
in order to find the best test on a set
of samples is the following
you only need to draw log and different
problem instance samples because that's
that's the pseudo dimension and that
ensures near optimality and for each
instance I'm going to draw a single
random hyperplane okay and so recall
that the expected cost of a particular
value of s is in fact an expectation or
many hyperplane grasped infinitely many
hyperplane Rodge but we only need to
draw a single random hyperplane and then
we need to we can write down the
empirical average of op star as a
function of s this is a closed form
expression as I told you already and
this has only polynomially many
intervals and each interval is a linear
or quadratic in toe has a linear or
quadratic empirical average and we can
then if I find the best test within each
interval and efficiently find the
globally best s now this so we proved
very we proved identical results for in
fact more general classes of rounding
functions so for example well it can be
a sigmoid like rounding function which
is parameterized by a single parameter
and we show that the pseudo dimension of
observe a is Theta of log N and we also
prove we also present a efficient
computationally efficient algorithm
selection procedures for these for this
class of rounding functions so this
brings me to the end of my talk so in
summary our work contributes to analysis
of algorithms because we provide
theoretical grounding to application
specific algorithm selection and we also
push the boundaries of learning theory
because the algorithms that we consider
the function classes that we consider
correspond to our algorithms that are
significantly complex multistage and
also randomized so we also nailed on the
intrinsic complexity of these algorithms
by providing both upper and lower bounds
the solar dimension of these classes and
what is surprising as was pointed out in
the previous talk is that these these
are tight bonds which are super constant
despite the fact that the algorithm
class themselves have only constantly
many parameters in my talk with a couple
of future directions can we generalize
our SDP rounding analysis to more
rounding functions and to more you know
SDP based problems and another question
is or the kind of algorithms that we
have considered can be run efficiently
in practice but what is their algorithms
like SATs always may be which which run
pretty slow in which take a long time
and hence to actually compute the
empirical performance of those
algorithms it's impossible to you know
actually run them full run them to
completion so in such a case how do we
handle this problem and how do we
provide theoretical guarantees so those
are the future directions and that's it
Thanks if you have any questions
it seems to me that in your first
application you ended up with two
parameters right yeah it was impressive
to see how this works I'm curious I mean
practical algorithm configuration
settings often have dozens of them right
so yeah pieces like this it should be I
mean it depends on the problem but it
should be possible like even Rishi had
in his in this model they extract the
even viscous multiple parameter
algorithms families so similarly it
should be possible to you know or split
up the space of parameters into these
grids and within each of which the
algorithm has almost similar behavior
but I can see that depends on the
algorithm class that you are you know
considering whether that's easy to do or
not